let's let's go to like the trivial case
of just texting back and forth
what if we create a large language Model
fine-tuned A manolus
and
while you're at work it'll replace
every once in a while you just activate
the auto manolus
you know text them exactly in your way
is that is that cheating I can't wait
I mean it's the same guy I cannot wait
seriously like but wait wouldn't that
have a big impact on you emotionally
because now I'm replaceable I love that
seriously I would love that I would love
to be replaced I would love to be
replaceable I would love to have a
digital twin that you know we don't have
to wait for me to to die or to disappear
in a plane crash or something
um to to replace me like I'd love that
model to be constantly learning
constantly evolving adapting with every
one of my changing growing self uh as as
I'm growing I want that AI to grow and I
think this will be extraordinary number
one when I'm you know giving advice
being able to be there for more than one
person you know why does someone need to
be at MIT to get advice from me like did
you know people in India could download
it and you know so many so many students
contact me from across the world who
want to come and spend the summer with
me
I wish they could do that
all of them like you know we don't have
room for all of them but I wish I could
do that to all of them and
um that that aspect is the
democratization of of relationships I
think that that is extremely beneficial
the other aspect is I want to interact
with that system I want to look inside
the hood I want to sort of evaluate it I
want to basically see if when I see it
from the outside the emotional
parameters are off or the cognitive
parameters are off or the set of ideas
that I'm giving are not quite right
anymore I want to see how that system
evolves I want to see the impact of
exercise or sleep on sort of my own
cognitive system I want to be able to
sort of
decompose my own behavior in a set of
parameters that can evaluate and look at
my own personal growth I can sort of I'd
love to sort of at the end of the day
have my model say well you know you
didn't quite do well today like you know
you you weren't quite there and sort of
grow from that experience and I I think
the concept of basically being able to
become more aware of our own
personalities become more aware of our
own identities maybe even interact with
ourselves and sort of hear how we are
being perceived
I think would be immensely helpful in
self-growth in self-actualization
self-aducation
the experiments I would do on that thing
because one of the challenges of course
is you might not like what you see
in your interaction and you might say
well this the model is not accurate but
then you have to should probably
consider the possibility the model is
accurate and that there's actually flaws
in your mind I would definitely prod and
see how many biases I have with
different kinds I don't know and I would
of course go to the extremes I would go
like um how jealous can I make this
thing like what what at which stages
does it get super jealous you know or at
which stages does he get angry can I
like provoke it can I get it like yeah
but not only triggers can I get it to go
like lose its mind like go completely
nuts just don't exercise for a few days
that's basically it yes uh I mean that
that's that's an interesting way to prod
yourself almost like a a self therapy
session and and the beauty of such a
model is that if I am replaceable if the
parts that I currently do are
replaceable
if that's amazing because it frees me up
to work on other parts that I don't
currently have time to develop
maybe all I'm doing is giving the same
advice over and over and over again like
just let my AI do that and I can work on
the next stage and the next stage and
the next stage so I think in terms of
freeing up like
they say a programmer someone cannot do
the same thing twice so this is the
second time you write a program to do it
and I wish I could do that for my own
existence I could just like you know
figure out things keep improving
improving improving and once I've nailed
it let the AI loosen that and maybe even
let the AI better it better than I could
have but doesn't the concept of you said
me and I can work on new things but
doesn't that uh break down because you
said digital twin but there's no reason
it can't be
millions of digital monols are aren't
you lost in the sea of manosis the
original uh is hardly the original it's
just one of millions I
I want to have the room to grow
maybe the new version of me that that
that the actual me will get slightly
worse sometimes slightly better other
times when it gets slightly better I'd
like to emulate that
and have a much higher standard to meet
and keep going but does it make you sad
that your loved ones
physical real loved ones might kind of
like start cheating on you with the
other minosis I I want to be there 100
of them for each of them
so I I have zero perks or zero zero
quirms about me being physically me like
zero jealousy wait a minute but is isn't
that like
don't we hold on to that isn't that why
we're afraid of death we don't want to
lose this thing we have going on isn't
that an ego death when there's a bunch
of other menoses you get to look at them
they're not you
they're just very good copies of you
they get to live a life
the I mean it's fear of missing out it's
fomo they get to have interactions all
right and you don't get to have those
interactions there's two aspects of
every person's life there's what you
give to others and there's what you
experience yourself yeah
life truly ends when you experiencing
ends
but the others experiencing you doesn't
need to end oh
but your experience you could still I
guess you're saying the digital twin
does not limit your ability to truly the
experience to experience as a human
being the the the the downside is when
you know my wife or my kids will have a
really emotional interaction with my
digital twin and I won't know about it
so I will show up and they now have the
baggage but I don't so basically what
makes interactions between humans unique
in this sharing and exchanging kind of
way is the fact that we are both shaped
by every one of our interactions I think
the model of the digital twin works for
dissemination of knowledge of advice
Etc where you know I want to have wise
people give me advice across history I
want to have chat with Gandhi but Gandhi
won't necessarily learn from me
but I will learn from him so in a way
you know the the dissemination and the
democratization rather than the building
of relationships so the the emotional
aspect is that there should be an alert
when the AI system is interacting with
your loved ones and all of a sudden it
starts getting like
emotionally fulfilling like a magical
moment there should be okay stop AI
system like freezes there's an alert on
your phone you need to take over yeah
yeah I take over and then whoever I was
speaking with they can have the the AI
or like one of the AIS this is such a
tricky thing to get right I mean it's
still I mean there's go
uh this is going to go wrong in so many
interesting ways that we're gonna have
to learn as a society yeah yeah that in
the process of trying to automate our
tasks and having a digital twin
you know for me personally if I could
have a relatively good copy of myself
uh I would set it to start answering
emails but I would start setting to
start tweeting I would like to replace
it gets better what if that one is
actually way better than you yeah
exactly then you're like uh well I
wouldn't want that because why because
then I would never be able to live up to
like what if the people that love me
start loving that thing and then I'm I
will always I already fall short be
falling short even more so listen I'm a
professor the stuff that I give to the
world is the stuff that I teach but most
much more importantly sorry number one
the stuff that I teach number two the
discoveries that we make in my research
group but much more importantly the
people that I train
they are now out there in the world
teaching others
if you look at my own trainees they are
extraordinarily successful professors
so Andrew kundanji at Stanford Alex
Stark at Imp in Vienna Jason Ernst at
UCLA Andrea spanning at CMU each of them
I'm like wow they're better than I am
and I love that
so maybe your role
will be to train better versions of
yourself
and they will be your legacy not you
doing everything but you training much
better version of Lex Friedman than you
are
and then they go off to do their mission
which is in many ways what this
mentorship model of Academia does but
the legacy is ephemeral it doesn't
really live anywhere the Legacy it's not
like written somewhere it just lives
through them but you can continue
improving and you can continue making
even better versions of you
yeah but they'll do better than me and
they're creating you first it's awesome
but it's
um
you know there's a ego that says there's
a value to an individual and it feels
like this process decreases the value of
the individual this meat bag
all right if there's good digital copies
of people then uh there's more
flourishing of human thought and ideas
and experiences but there's less value
to the individual human I I don't have
any such limitations I I basically I
don't I don't have that feeling at all
like I remember one of our interviews I
was basically saying you know the
meaning of life you had asked me and I
was like I came back and I was like I
felt useful today
and I was at my maximum I was I was you
know
like 100 and I gave good ideas and I was
a good person with a good advisor was a
good husband a good father that was a
great day because it was useful and if I
can be useful to more people by having
digital twin I will be liberated
because my urge to be useful
will will be satisfied
doesn't matter whether it's direct me or
indirect me whether it's my students
that I've trained my AI that I've
trained
I think there's a there's a sense that
my mission in life is being accomplished
and I can work on my self-growth
I mean that's a very Zen State that's
why people love you this is understand
you've achieved but do you think most of
humanity will be able to achieve that
kind of thing is the people people
really hold on to the value of Their Own
ego that's it's not just being useful
being useful is nice as long as it
builds up this reputation and that meat
bag is known as being useful therefore
has more value right people really don't
want to let go of that ego thing I I one
of the books that I reprogram my brain
with at night was called uh ego is the
enemy it goes in the atom ego is the
enemy and basically being able to just
let go like
uh my advisor used to say you can
accomplish anything
as long as you don't seek to get credit
for it
that's beautiful to hear especially from
a person who's existing in Academia
you're right the Legacy lives through
the people you mention it's the actions
it's the outcome